la enorme columna de vehículos blindados
rusos que avanza lentamente hacia la
capital ucraniana parece haberse
dispersado ahora dividida en grupos más
pequeños estas últimas imágenes de
satélite muestran a los tanques
avanzando en el norte y el oeste de kiev
algunos vehículos están escondidos en el
bosque su artillería puesta en
posiciones de tiro las fuerzas rusas
están presentes en varios frentes que
rodean la ciudad y parecen estar
reforzando su control a las puertas de
kiev los combates continúan las ciudades
de butch ajusto mel e irving se
esfuerzan por resistir al mismo tiempo
las autoridades instan a los ciudadanos
a huir pero deben hacerlo a pie cruzando
el río sin saber a dónde ir recibiendo
una bendición antes de su viaje
mira los regalos que se envían desde el
cielo son esos estúpidos rusos los que
matan a los civiles los tanques rusos
también se acercan al suroeste de la
capital los habitantes de la zona están
preparados para resistir
somos civiles de la defensa del
territorio no estamos preparados para
luchar contra los tanques pero sí contra
las tropas de tierra tenemos 26
kalashnikov de calibre 5.45 pero no hay
suficientes para todos
en el noreste la región de broward está
inmersa en intensos combates por aquí
pasa la principal carretera kiev un
punto estratégico crucial para los
soldados ucranianos pero una gran parte
ya ha caído en manos rusas en cinco días
sus tanques han avanzado más de 80
kilómetros
no no tenemos miedo sé que nos defienden
no tenemos miedo no tengo miedo de morir
extras
lo siento por mis hijos y mis nietos no
tengo miedo de nada
fui soldado durante la época soviética
la otan es una organización poderosa
porque tiene miedo de defender a ucrania
mientras quienes se preparan para un
asalto desde todos los frentes casi la
mitad de sus habitantes ha abandonado la
ciudad